[Music]
ray we are so excited to have you here
tonight at Stanford thank you for
joining us I'm so glad to be here well
ray as a tribute as our little tribute
to Bridgewater we are going to videotape
this conversation okay but I had to veto
any of this life scoring stuff I'm just
not at your level and hundred feedback
yet we've got a lot to cover your life
your principles and how you think about
the future but before we start I want to
get a feel for our audience here tonight
so please raise your hand if you have
read or our reading Ray's book
principles Wow Wow pretty good okay and
for the rest of you how many of you are
planning to read principles yeah they're
an ambitious group for anyone else out
there do you at least have your own
moral principles yeah okay good good
let's start back in the early days on
Long Island no you were quite the
capitalist growing up you were a
paperboy a lawnmower a snow shovel er
and a golf caddy and at the ripe old age
of 12 you made your first investment in
the stock market talk to us about how
that even happens well you know
everybody was talking about the stock
market there's no big deal really hmm at
the time in the 60s the stock market was
the hottest it has ever been literally
if he got a haircut or anything
everybody would talk to you about the
stock market and so when I was catting
they were talking to me about the stock
market and I'd take my $6 a bag I would
take my $12 and and when I got $50 I had
put it in the stock market it was just a
natural thing to do and it did pretty
well the first investment yeah I it was
the only company that I ever heard of
that was selling for less than $5 a
share so I figured I could buy more
shares which meant if it went off I'd
make more money that was my rationale
that was
rationale right and it was a company
that was about to go broke but another
company acquired it it tripled in value
and I thought this game's easy I can
make a lot of money game's not easy but
that's what got me hooked so you got a
bit of a rolling start but you continue
to invest through high school and
university and you later enrolled at a
business school one we like to call the
Stanford of the East where you met of
course Joel Peterson and Joel was in my
head group and we have good memories now
you know we'll talk about those later
now for your summer internship many of
your classmates were going to Wall
Street and they were seeking these
glamorous equity trading positions you
on the other hand saw that a role in
commodities trading which at the time
wasn't just less prestigious it was
pretty obscure for an MBA to seek out
that kind of a role so talk to us about
what that experience of going against
the grain taught you well it was I
figured more they had low margin
requirements right you only had to
basically put up about 10% of the money
so I figured if you're gonna be right
you'll make more money because the low
margin requirements so I got hooked on
commodity trading and then there wasn't
anybody who would go from Harvard
Business School so this was 1972 the
summer of 1972 when I went to the
director of commodities and I begged for
a job and he gave me a job and that was
just before the 1973 oil crisis and the
oil shock and then Wall Street went to
hell and commodities became hot and I
was lucky and so I went into commodities
so you were hot property by second year
and I never did I never really knew
anything about commodities other than
the summer job but I was then a hot
property because there was no Harvard
Business School type person in
commodities so I got a job which was
stupid to hire me but they did and then
that company then
got into trouble then I went to another
company and I did that for about a year
and then started Bridgewater so I'll I
just want to you skipped over something
there and I many of us here in the room
ray we know you as a master a master of
thoughtful disagreement okay but you
didn't have that concept fully nailed
back in those early days so talk to us
about that disagreement you had with
your boss on New Year's Eve well I mean
we got drunk and then we you know we uh
I loved him and and he was a good guy
and but what he did he but he drove home
he he totaled his car his wife chewed
him out because he they missed their
party and he came in with a black eye
and he didn't fire me that he didn't
fire did not fire me okay
and then it was another incident that
caused him to fire me
but either I want to know what got you
fired can you tell us what anyway they
anywhere we that that was the best thing
that actually happened to me because
then I was on my own now some of our
career advisors around here we might
frame that one as passion right and it
was it's it's it you know kind of in
retrospect it was a stupid thing to do
right but it was it was just what I was
like at the time I guess and so you go
ahead and start Bridgewater associates
from your two-bedroom apartment in New
York so you're 26 years old you're a
first-time entrepreneur and a
professional investor now something
those roles would seem to have in common
is you have a high risk of being wrong
and making mistakes talk to us about
your relationship with mistakes and how
those led to your principles yeah I
think
just generally as an entrepreneur or in
the markets you have to think
differently in order to be successful
I'm the markets whatever the view is is
built into the price because it reflects
the consensus and as an entrepreneur
starting out of business you have to
think differently and there's a high
risk of being wrong and so what I
learned over that period you have to be
audacious you have to think differently
you have to be confident and then you
also experience a high risk of being
wrong and I think we're going to go to a
clip of of one of those really big
mistakes that I made that changed my
whole approach to decision making so I
in 1980-81 I had calculated that
American banks had left lend a lot more
money to foreign countries and those
countries are going to be able to pay
back and that we were going to have a
debt crisis and I thought that that
would cause an economic collapse and in
August 1982 Mexico defaulted on its debt
and I received a lot of attention for
that and I was asked to speak to
Congress at that time and I was also on
Wall Street week and we brought a clip
of that so you'll you'll get a sense of
that so is that can you hit the button
and show the clip mr. chairman mr.
Mitchell it's a great pleasure and a
great honor to be able to appear before
you and examination with what is going
wrong with our economy the economy is
now flat teetering on the brink of
failure you were recently quoted in an
article you said I can say this with
absolute certainty because I know how
markets work I can say with absolute
certainty that if you look at the
liquidity base in the corporations and
the world as a whole that there's such a
reduced level of liquidity that you
can't return to an era of stagflation
wasn't I arrogant incredibly arrogant I
couldn't have been
more wrong I was so wrong that was the
exact bottom in the stock market August
1982 Mexico defaulting on its debt and
was the bottom in the stock market we
had a big bull mark and I had then I
think like eight people at Bridgewater
and I had to let him go and I was so
broke that I had to borrow $4,000 from
my dad in order to pay for my family
bills and that was very painful and it
changed my whole approach to decision
making because it made me think in the
future how do I know I'm not wrong how
do I know I'm right
it gave me the humility that I needed to
balance with my audacity and it made me
bring in people that would disagree with
me so I wanted to find the smartest
people that would disagree with me and I
really you know started to think about
how would I deal with disagreement and I
would say that this is this is a big
thing it's such a pleasure to be here by
the way because you're beginning this
phase of your career you're just about
to this what I call the second phase of
your life first phase of your life is
when you're dependent on others and
you're learning second phase of your
life is that when you're working and
then eventually others become dependent
on you and in that second phase it's
totally different and I'm going into my
third phase and so to be able to sort of
pass along some things that were helpful
to me where is is a treat and along
those lines I would say you're gonna
keep having failures as well as
successes and it's in the failures that
you learn the most and so my attitude
began to change in terms of making
decisions most importantly I would view
every failure as a puzzle that would
give me a gem if I could solve the
puzzle and the puzzle was what would I
do differently in the future so that I
wouldn't have that bad outcome so and if
I could saw
that that would give me the gem and the
gem was the principle and the other
thing that I did was write down all my
decision-making principles one I would
make a decision I would take the time
and say what are my criteria for making
that decision and that was so available
I'd want to pass that along to you
you're going to encounter so many things
in your life and you're just gonna make
decisions like that if instead you pause
and you think what are my criteria for
making that decision you write it down
and then you reflect on it you'll start
to realize that the same thing happens
over and over again and when the next
one comes along you'll reflect on that
principle and you'll refine it and it
serves the purpose also of letting you
communicate very effectively with others
so when I started my business it was
great because we would all know what we
could expect and why well and that whole
process so that I mean I think it's
really that whole notion of the best
comes from learning from mistakes and
doing that in a systematic way failure
is just part of the journey and to get
to those mistakes ran to bring them out
into the open you needed an idea
meritocracy and for that you needed
radical truth and radical transparency
talk to us a little bit about those two
columns yeah I don't know exact you have
that diagram okay Zack yeah so this is
this is this is this is the way it
worked for me so in order to be six in
order to be successful
I needed independent thinkers who would
disagree with me and that we would
disagree with each other because
otherwise it's that false confidence how
do you stress test each other to get to
the best idea so I needed independent
thinkers who were also wanting to go for
the audacious goals so if you have
independent thinkers how are you going
to get past the disagreement you
actually have to have a system for
disagreeing well and getting past the
disagreement so I needed an idea
meritocracy in other words an actual
process that organizes disagreement to
get past it and
in order to do that then I needed to
have that principle that I needed to
write it down and we all needed to know
what that rules are and then we need to
make these systems and then when we did
that that changed everything right that
thoughtful disagreement because it's
collective decision-making in which you
significantly increase the probabilities
of making a right decision I think the
greatest tragedy of people probably and
one of the greatest tragedies of mankind
is people who hold opinions in their
mind that they're attached to that are
wrong that they could so easily
stress-test
and significantly raise the probability
of being right so we needed to do that
and when we did that we had at our
successes and our failures but we but
the people believed in that idea
meritocracy and and it was fair because
the system if if you have a system in
which you can fight for your arguments
and you know that the system is going to
be fair you can care more and so that's
the top organization I needed to and
that was the key right whatever success
I've had in my life has had more to do
with my knowing how to deal with what I
don't know then because of anything I
know and that idea meritocracy that
triangulation with smart people sorry I
want to go a layer deeper on this
radical truth and radical transparency I
think for many of us hearing it here
it's very hard to argue with the logic
of what you're saying
and yet the culture at Bridgewater feels
quite foreign to what most of us have
experienced in our personal or
professional lives what is it about this
concept that is so difficult for us to
embrace by the way that's the
competitive edge right because if it was
you know if you were to say what's the
edge that's the that's the edge I think
we have ego and blind spots barriers
that stand in our way and so that notion
of attach to what you know is such a big
thing for your ego or your blind spot
and and so there's a subliminal reaction
when you're
disagrees rather than producing
curiosity there it produces antagonism
like it's an amygdala reaction and I
think a lot has to do with the education
system too you know you're rewarded for
knowing or you're rewarded for not
making mistakes rather than knowing what
your weaknesses are so in order to go
through that it one has to
intellectually go through it to say does
it make sense so let's say we're gonna
have a relationship and you're now
you're working there and you're my
partner great and I owe ya what is who
it's like but you would say you would I
would say do you do you want me to know
do you want to know what I really think
do you want to tell me what you really
think do you want to know your
weaknesses hmm do you want me to know my
weaknesses intellectually you you would
say you would want to know your
weaknesses why wouldn't you want to know
your weaknesses emotionally that can be
difficult so it takes adapting to so
what we we describe it as there's to use
there's the and this is correct in terms
of literally there is a conscious
thoughtful you that might say I would
like me to do those things I'd like to
know my weaknesses so I can know how to
deal with them and then there's an
emotional you that's subliminal and it's
really the battle with your to use that
you have with yourself and once people
start to realize that and they come in
that environment then they see that
they're really more struggling with
themselves than each other so that
radical truthfulness so the right way it
is is minore der to have the radical
truthfulness you have to put what you
honestly think on the table can you do
that and then transparency means that
you can get to see everything so what I
did was put everybody could see
everything so that was the main thing so
when I would make decisions I would I'd
be doing I'd be very very right
we open about what I was doing in the
most difficult decisions that we would
make and then I would refer to the
principles and then I'd have everybody
challenge me on whether that made sense
and so our intellectual approach
overcame our emotional barriers but I
think it's like that for physical you
know I was HR McMasters here and he was
a great host to me down and I got to see
Ranger School and I think about those
put those people pushing themselves and
how they were pushing themselves and
they were doing the physical equivalent
although the Bentall was equally
important and that produces that
particular strain they wanted that and
that's what Bridgewater is about but
it's not for everybody just like some
people would watch out of the Army
Rangers it's off for everybody
but it's powerful because you build
these you build meaningful work and
meaningful relationships in other words
I think that that's the power if you are
committed to your mission like you're
excited you we're going to do this thing
together maybe a startup or maybe
whatever it is you're on that mission
together and then at the same time
you're on that mission you have these
meaningful relationships which means
total honesty and with that total
honesty and that meaningful relationship
you get a joy out of the relationship as
well as you get a joy about being
successful and it doesn't have that
two-faced nature it doesn't have
politics behind it it's just
straightforward so yeah that's what it's
like so that's really what you're
avoiding it's the kind of politics and
the gossiping that you might get in the
normal world albeit it's not for
everyone not everyone can kind of take
this it change it changes the it changes
the ethic like there's no talking behind
somebody's back and and the reason it is
is it's almost like first of all it's
unproductive if you're talking about
behind somebody's back then you're not
dealing with the particular issue in a
place like where we value about anybody
speaking up with their point of view
then you can raise it and you can then
deal with it but
also it then becomes sort of an ethic
thing that like don't you have the guts
to talk about what you're saying and so
if you have the guts so it's almost
humiliating to talk behind somebody's
back and so that standard then carries
forward and it's you know it leads to
that kind of radical truthfulness that
radical transparency so you have some
people you know it's it's not at all for
and then you have people who couldn't
work anywhere else because they that
wouldn't want to work they go into the
company and everybody's smiling and the
giving high-fives and whatever and
they're all talking - I had each other's
backs there's a lot of politics going on
and that they can't deal with so a lot
of people wouldn't want to work anywhere
else and some people it's not the right
place for Surrey you've built a machine
really that supports this culture and
you also have a belief that humans are
machines I think few companies have done
more than Bridgewater to try and use
data to understand their employees to
put their attributes and their talents
into numbers so I'm curious if you see a
tension between this explicit labeling
of a person's abilities with what Carol
Dweck at Stanford might call this growth
mindset the idea that a person's
abilities talents even intelligence is
more fluid and can change well I think
the I'm just trying to be as accurate as
possible and change if it change occurs
then is reflected in the numbers and
everybody sees the change so it's a lot
but but I think that at any point in
time
you have to be realistic of where you
are and you have to recognize that
people have different strengths and
weaknesses and if you're not dealing
with that that that's a particular
problem stands in the way of the growth
of the particular people and then also
people making choices about other people
there right so if I'm your boss or or
making that decision if I'm not open if
I don't give you that constant feedback
and also if I'm not collecting data from
others because I'm not sure than I'm
right so the data kind of helps to speak
for itself in terms of understanding
what it's what a person is like
so I think it's you know it's a good
thing though it doesn't mean that you
don't stand in the way of evolution it
means that whatever extent evolution
occurs you get to see it so I think that
the bigger context here raised many of
us will be graduating in a few months
and some of us will be making a choice
do we return to a job and a function we
know how to do that suits us well or do
we branch out down a new on tested path
from what you've seen at Bridgewater
what might you advise us and how we
think about that this is that this is
the time for your adventure you're
experimenting you're learning right for
for that experimentation and I'll
guarantee you that wherever you're gonna
be in five years is going to change you
know it go for the experience but I
think the most important thing I would
say when you're going on that adventure
is to understand how to triangulate well
what I mean is find the three or four
smartest people who are dealing with the
most important questions that you're
facing particularly if they're willing
to disagree with each other and disagree
with you on that and then with that
triangulation where are their areas of
the disagreement that'll bubble to the
surface and you'll find out what you
know what might be you'll learn a lot
and then through that that humility you
go through experiences and make the most
out of your failures the adventurous do
make the discovery go for it all right
right all right well we're done thank
you very much joking but the other the
other question we face Ray is what type
of organization do we join so I think
culture is the most important thing I
think who you're with okay and where you
are is much more important than what you
do sorry let me take you up on that so
let's assume you're in our shoes you're
about to go into the working world and
you want to work in an idea meritocracy
many in this room are going to join
large organizations that have embedded
hierarchies cultures and norms
so talk to us in a practical sense about
how we can bring some of these ideas to
the workplace well you've got to you you
have the choice to get working wherever
culture you want the most important
thing is do you work in the culture now
you were raised here in your education
and before to try to have the
opportunity to make sense of things okay
so I would go into your job and say if
something doesn't make sense to me do I
have the right to say it doesn't make
sense to me and ask you and why it makes
sense and to be able to probe you or do
I not have that right and I think you
should think hard about whether you want
to be in the organization that doesn't
give you that right so I think the most
info Stan fundamental thing is is to be
in that kind of organization with
humility in other words recognizing that
you might not but you always have the
right to make sense of things and if
something doesn't make sense to say it
doesn't make sense so that I would say
that that would be the most important
thing for me if you're gonna learn
because otherwise you're gonna be
somebody slept you know they're going to
say do these things and you're just
going to run and follow their
instructions and so on and you're not
gonna learn if you're following their
instructions because you have to think
for yourself I think and you've given us
plenty of tools to do that right I want
to talk a little bit about your legacy
you've accumulated these principles over
40 years you've decided to share them as
part of what you're calling this third
phase in your life a question Joel often
asks the class is what does winning look
like to you you've invested huge amounts
of your time and energy in this public
facing role what does winning look like
in this third phase I think through life
it's all just a matter of personal
evolution and contributing to evolution
for me you evolve and there's an
instinctual reaction that I had that
what I wanted to do is pass along the
things that are valuable to me so I can
move beyond that and my son at 2014 when
I was making this transition
this book Joseph Campbell's hero of
Thousand Faces and he describes these
various phases of our lives which I laid
it to and I won't take you through them
all but there's a call to adventure you
go in the venture you have your ups and
downs you reflect on them and so on and
then when you get to this stage in your
life they the thing that you want more
is not to be successful you've done it
you don't want to be more successful you
want to help others be successful
without you
and that's the that's what I feel and
then when I feel like if I'd done that
best job I will have done my best job
and we're good and so that's my
instinctual reaction at the start well
you've given us a lot start and I know
there's plenty out there who haven't
read the book so you're not quite there
yet but I want it I want to say just for
everybody and I'll mention it what maybe
later what I did was there's the book
and then I converted the book into an
app that has the actual cases of
Bridgewater's so you could go into
meetings and you can actually see this
in actually called principles in action
it's a free app on the Apple Store and
it'll take you into that so you get a
sense of what the thing is like plenty
more case studies we love those Ray's
now ray we could spend another error on
these principles but unfortunately
you've got far too many other
perspectives we want to probe you on
let's start with history you're a
student of history you've stated that
everything that happens is just another
one of those so I'm curious when you
look at today our stage in the economic
cycle our political tensions our
geopolitical tensions
what's the historical precedent for what
you see and what does that tell us about
what happens next well I think it's
there were cause-effect relationships
and then they repeat through history I
think it's important to not just assume
that because they happen in the past
that they'll happen again but also to
understand the cause-effect
relationships so what answering your
question I like to refer to both
one of the things that I learned was
that I was every almost every time I was
surprised I was surprised by things that
happen didn't that happen OTT happen in
my lifetime but happened many times
before and as a result of that I really
found that I really needed to understand
history and why things happen before it
and that in the tooth out 2007 because I
studied what happened in the Great
Depression let me we were able to
anticipate the 2008 financial crisis
because of what happened in 1929 and 32
so the period that I think that was most
analogous is the late 1930s and I'll
explain why and this is just the
mechanics of it we had a debt crisis in
1932 1929 to 1932 and in both of those
cases interest rates hit zero only two
times in the century that that happened
when interest rates hit zero they had to
the central banks had to print money and
buy financial assets we call that
quantitative easing those purchases of
financial assets put financial asset
prices up and as a result of pushing
that up it makes the economy go up so
1932 to 1937 the economy the stock
market went up everything went up in
much the same way as it did from 2009
until recently and then but because they
did cause phonetic bought financial
assets those with financial and assets
benefited more than those who didn't
have financial assets and there were
other factors like we have technology
today replacing people and as a result
we began had a large wealth gap so if
you look today the top one-tenth of one
percent of the populations net worth is
equal to the bottom 90% combined and if
you take that or measures like that the
wealth gap is the same as it was in that
period of
time that 1930s period of time and with
a large wealth gap and differences in
values then you have populism the
emergence of populism populism of the
left and populism of the right and if
you go through history the law if you
were to say when did the last time you
had populism in major countries it was
in that period of time for similar
reasons and with that time also you had
the classic rising of a power to
challenge as an existing power in that
case it was Germany rising to challenge
the British the British Empire Ln and
then Japan and Asia and like now we have
China rising and that there's a calm a
rivalry a conflict so the only periods
of time that you could see that was
analogous recently the most recent
period of time is like that so I would
say what what are the big issues of the
time the big issues today are that there
is a limited ability of central banks to
ease monetary policy because we have
interest rates near zero most cases
around the world and so the capacity of
central banks teas is limited we have a
very large wealth gap and with that we
have polarity a lot of political
polarity democracy even being challenged
by that polarity right and then you have
these conflicts around the world and so
that populism of the left and populism
of the right has big economic
implications have what it'll mean for
Tax Policy and what will it mean for
even conflicts between countries and so
we have that rising power situation so
that period of time looks most analogous
to today you've covered a lot of things
there ray and we'll try and dive into a
few at the time we have left on a high
level it's a pretty shocking comparison
to make and we know how the 1930s ended
do you believe that on our current
trajectory we're heading towards some
sort of conflict
well what we're certainly heading to
different kinds of conflict the question
I think is how we're going to handle
them we certainly are headed
domestically to lots of conflict right
if you were to take the polls of the
Republican Party that is the most
conservative it has been ever the
Democratic Party is the most liberal it
is lever the the voting according to
party lines is the most it has been ever
94 percent of the votes are according to
party lines and so we certainly have an
internal conflict and that internal
conflict has to do about the combination
I think of the economic conditions that
left and the writer that let's say
socialism and capitalism are our issues
and then there's also ways that we are
to be together I would say you know I
don't know that we're clear on what
principles bind us together as a country
I mean I think we should go to
principles what principles bind us
together as a country what are we
believe in what are the principles that
divide us but anyway we are having more
domestic conflict I think and then
international conflict there is this
this there will be a challenge a
competition that is going on between the
United States and China and other places
but particularly the United States and
China which is a whole other discussion
that doesn't have to be a military
conflict though it could be and it
depends I think on how we handle the
conflict so I think there's the China
American relation that's a topic we
could digress into if you want to cover
it but there's I think it's all how are
we going to be with each other right so
let's say this this issue of the wealth
gap and the left and the right my big
fear is that the conflict and then just
badly ends your knee
policies can cause us to have worse
conditions than we need to there's like
there's there's enough resources to go
around to move us toward more equal
opportunities in various ways we can
deal with this together but yeah I think
that we're an environment in which
conflict is going to be more problematic
than we have actually experienced now
ray there's two issues there's the
external conflict there's the internal
conflict in our own country
you've talked about redistribution and
you've recently published a piece how
and why capitalism needs to be reformed
and a need for greater redistribution
because it's tax day April 15th
apologies would you agree that a person
of your resources and your wealth should
be taxed more by the US government to
help further this yes I I believe that
it's inevitable that we should yes I
think but I think the real question is
the most important is are we striving to
have a country what is our American
dream are we striving to have a country
that is something the court long lines
of equal opportunity are we striving
along how do we feel when there are
school districts that don't have
adequate anywhere near adequate
resources that there's not enough it's
it goes to nutrition
there's nothing approaching equal
education
I broke the economy to up into two parts
so that I could see it because it gets
lost in the averages so the top forty
percent on the bottom sixty percent
because I wanted to see what the
majority of people the bottom sixty
percent is like and certain things like
the average in the top forty percent
they will spend five times as much on
their children's education than in the
bottom 60% and and school districts are
you know starved for resources and
there's a whole different life I can
rattle it
if you want to go see it I'd really love
you to go see it it's a study and that's
on LinkedIn and it shows the outcomes so
I guess what I'm looking at that I would
say that's not I think a fair system and
beyond that it's a system that threatens
to destroy us if we don't find a way to
reform it now I'm a capitalist I want I
do believe in the idea of working hard
and earning and then saving and what
capitalism is is you buy a instrument of
capitalism now you buy stocks that's
capitalism you own a piece of that
business and I believe that that's
fantastic but what has to like anything
everything has got to be improved with
time with Reformation so are we
producing the outcomes that we want so
when you read that you see if we're
producing the outcomes we want I don't
think so so I'm saying I think we have
to modify that now how we do that is
going to most importantly be a very it
has to be a good exercise engineering
exercise that I think has to be first
it's got to be done in a bipartisan way
because I think this division is a
problems and I really believe in
thoughtful disagreement so if you bring
together people who will living in these
communities and then and then you have
metrics right I think it would be great
if the leadership it could be the
leadership of the United States it could
be the leadership of the state says that
this is a critical issue that we have to
deal with that they put metrics on it so
they own it in other words numbers and
key you know KPIs and they say here's
that condition is that living standard
the same or is it rising and one of the
what are we doing in terms education and
with those measures then work together
in terms of doing sensible engineering I
have my own views of what could be done
but you know how we get into that that's
a that's a whole conversation I'm not
sure so sure my views should be should
matter this is just one of other views
but if we
don't do it together and we don't treat
it as a really important critical issue
I think the most critical issue of our
time right now I think we're going to be
in trouble so yes of course that there
needs to be but there needs to be
redistribution of opportunity it's not
just redistribution of money but when
you pay that get the schoolbooks get the
nutrition get those basic things I think
that's fundamental well Ray we're at
least out of time for now I want to make
sure our audience here have the chance
to ask their questions of you so anyone
out there who has a question please
raise your hand we'll find you with a
microphone and then if you're selected
please stand up and introduce yourself
before you ask your question
hello my name is max I am mb1 I'm from
Russia so sorry I don't know the local
political landscape that well but my
question is having such a great
reputation knowledge and leadership
experience in this country why you are
not running for the presidents for the
President of the United States because
because I don't think me and the
political system would get along I I
don't think I'd I think it's a very
difficult system I don't think it would
be effective I think that the political
system even the way it's structured
where the two parties and the way they
go about it and and you know I think
it's a it's a challenge that's almost
impossible to win and I'm anyway on well
I I'm able at this moment in time this
short moment in time to pass along some
thoughts that others in that position or
any position might could take or leave
thanks for being here I'm Ida garma I'm
a first year MBA student I have two
questions if you want to be fair you
could just pick one to answer one is you
know we understand that you're really
quite quantitative and systematic about
the way you think about decisions for
investments for your business and in
personal life as well I'm wondering what
you think about this notion of intuition
do you believe in it do you use it and
my second question is you know I'm quite
inspired by how you talk about equality
of opportunity I think it's fantastic I
suspect that you have peers and
colleagues who may not think the same
things and how do you have conversations
with them about about this thing that
you're so passionate about yeah so the
first question yeah
intuition intuition yeah I think I think
decision-making is is a comedy is
subliminal and logical and fabulous
ideas come from subliminal
decision-making but they may you don't
know if they're great or not that you
have to reconcile them with the logic so
yes intuition is can be very very
valuable we feel that you see it it's
subliminal the ability to collect dots
connect dots and see things in that way
imagination all of that the some of the
best ideas come in a subliminal way like
if you're taking a hot shower and these
ideas come to you it's not like you're
sitting there working hard on those
ideas they come up there that can be
fabulous
I think the key is to reconcile them
with your logic because they could be
misleading too so yes I I would say
they're at least as valuable as the
logical idea so and the second question
was about what
those how do you have those
conversations with your peers oh I just
thought of thoughtful disagreement I
mean I love disagreement I just have to
say what I believe and others say what
they believe and then we have a
conversation about it
and I love it to be to do that openly so
if you were to sit here and have a
conversation I would welcome anybody who
has a different point of view have a
thoughtful conversation that's easy that
I don't see any reason why there
shouldn't be good thoughtful
disagreement hi right I'm well I mostly
FS here I'm a student and I know you
remember the Giving Pledge so I was
wondering what principles you apply to
your giving in order to maximize your
social return on investment in the same
way you did with your financial returns
yeah the saying that it's tougher to
give away money than it is to make it is
actually true because when you're
pursuing a profit you will know whether
you're succeeding or failing when you're
giving away money it's very difficult to
have those kinds of metrics and you and
weigh one thing or another it's a lot
more confusing but I tend to take the
same approach that I would in my
investing meaning I try to think in
terms of return on investment but I
don't think in terms of I think in terms
of double bottom line return on
investment in other words what is the
social impact it makes it has to stretch
your mind because how do you relate a
what is the value of saving alive what
is the value of an education how do you
weigh it doesn't have a common
denominator like return on investment
has a number it's money and it's how
that is so that becomes a challenge for
me it's very important to though to try
to do that so we'll establish key
performance indicators and do that but I
also relating to me is the passion like
I've decided how am I going to take that
approach and that approach I've I make
it a family activity my family members
different in varying degrees are
interested in their own
philanthropic efforts and each one of
them has their own particular passion I
think that's great so I would say that
when you get past the certain point what
you think about is what do you really
want to do you don't think about profit
as much as you think about like what do
you want to do and I think that maybe as
you get older or you feel more connected
yeah and you also realize the blessings
that I've had because I didn't have
anything and then I've evolved and you
see what other people are as that
marginal benefit of spending money on
yourself into being able to help other
people makes a big difference
so those things return on investment how
do I make it sustainable how do I
measure how do I judge how good we are
doing as a family how do i establish
principles we've got a whole bunch of
principles that people have to abide by
in order to do it well so it's a it's
similar but it's it's more difficult
because of the fact that you know you
can't account for it very well so like
if you were to think how what should you
give money to are you going to be able
to measure whether education here or
life or those are difficult questions to
answer but you you work yourself through
it
I joined The Giving Pledge mostly
because I learn a lot the the people and
there are in somewhat similar
circumstances and they brainstorm well
and it's you know it's a learning
process hi Reuben Arnold MBA 2 so I know
you've tried to transition out of the
company and transition controlled the
company several times last years as
you're moving into this third phase I
was wondering if you could speak a
little bit to the dynamics that might
have made that transition difficult well
i fortunately had this principal here's
the background something like nine years
ago I decided that I wanted to
transition it was important thing and I
didn't know how long it was going to
take me I thought it would take me about
two years because I was working with the
people for a number of years and I
thought it was going to be great but
then on the other hand I learned never
to believe
what I think is a theory I don't if I
haven't done something before
successfully then I can't assume that I
know how to do it so I said then I you
know it maybe it could take up to 10
years I think it took me about eight and
a half years in order to do that well so
you go down a journey um I didn't know
anything about governance I had just run
the company and with this with this idea
meritocracy that I put myself in a
position that I would report to this
management committee they could hire
fire me they could operate that way so
that I had myself held accountable to
this idea meritocracy and I thought this
thing was going to work I made the
transition and then with the difficulty
realized that it wouldn't work and we
all agreed that it wasn't working and
then we set up a governance system you
know the proper board and I realized I
learned a lot about governance and I
learned about how to pass those
responsibilities along to others and
then you know we work that out and it's
been about a year and a half since I
transitioned out of that so I think the
lesson is like I was saying if you
haven't done something three times
before successfully don't assume you can
do it and that was really helpful to me
so through that trial and error it was
part of the learning process so I think
that's the saying I guess that would be
the principle if you haven't done
something through successfully three
times before don't assume you know how
to do it hi Alyssa I'm an MBA one and
when people talk about economic
opportunity a lot of the times we talk
about children of the poor becoming rich
but we rarely talk about children of the
rich making room for other people and so
I was wondering if your emphasis on
equal opportunity affected the way that
you parent well yes see but I think I
had an experience because and I think my
kids were lucky because I didn't have I
had the most important things I
shouldn't say I didn't have anything I
had parents who loved me I was I had an
adequate nutrition I was well taken care
of
I went to a public high school but I
didn't have much more than that
and and then when I was for most of my
life my kids didn't have much more than
that so they got to the they know the
difference they know like on what the
marginal utility of having a lot is
relative to that it's not very much and
then you start to create that that sense
of value so my own experience affected
my reaction to it I don't know what it
would be like to be born rich and then
find out what that's like I don't know
what that would be like it must be much
more difficult in terms of that but so
my experience naturally told me the
differences and and I think that's it's
important understand there been a number
of studies on happiness around the world
probably Stanford's got their professors
who wants study happiness and the one
thing is that they found that there's no
correlation past the basic level of
money and happiness but the one thing
that is the most important thing that
seems to across communities is a sense
of community in what your relationships
your personal relationships and so I
think that that's you know affected my
approach but I wouldn't know how to do
that if I wasn't if I didn't experience
that I don't think maybe time for one
more question
hi I'm David and I'm a third-year
undergrad and your interviews and your
book you talk about some great leaders
like Steve Jobs and Lee Kuan Yew could
you talk about some of your favorite
stories of great character from people
like that great character stories of
great character stories of great
character well different qualities and
those two people but I think Lee Kuan
Yew was a person who was wise and
balanced and self-sacrificing a great
leader who had the vision and the common
sense and the wisdom to also suffer the
slings and arrows of his position to
make Singapore a very special place and
I you know had the opportunity to know
him a little bit and he was remarkable
people but I think that they were if you
read Joseph Campbell's book a hero of a
thousand faces you could almost say what
are the archetypical characteristics of
of great leaders and there's this
evolution and that's described in that
book in which people with a sense of
adventure and caring they go out on
their adventure and then they are on a
mission and they succeed and they fail
and they do it with other people and
that the mission and the other people
eventually becomes more important to
them than their themselves and then they
start to rise in terms of seeing things
different which i think is the essence
of what spirituality is spirituality I
don't mean religion I mean the sense of
connectedness to others and the whole
and when that becomes
more important to them than themselves
they become that's what constitutes
being a hero and so people like Lee Kuan
Yew and such people had those particular
qualities and made you know and did what
they did so there are many many many
cases I mean I'm saying this man over
here HR McMaster is is for me a hero for
me and so I see it all around me and I
think it is those qualities that make a
person a hero well ray we've got a few
minutes left you talked about
connectedness in touchy-feely language I
might say I feel more connected to you
now and you've been very generous you've
shared your principles with us and so as
a token of our gratitude we thought we
might share some of our principles with
you so this is I thought it would be a
thin book it's actually nearly as thick
as yours so this is some of our GSB
principles from a lot of students here
in the audience today oh cool yeah this
is for real this is real this is great
great these are your principles these
are on this map I do want to take one of
the things on the apt is part of the app
is a coach and one of the things on it
is the coach allows you to describe I'm
in this situation what principle is best
for that situation so because you just
don't want to pile of principles you
want to go to find the ones that are
most appropriate and one of the most
important things about it is it allows
you to put your principles in and so you
could take your principles and drop it
into that coach I'm gonna be really
interested I think that's the most
important thing I think we're in an era
where we're confused about principles
that I don't think we spend enough time
thinking about principles we think about
doing so much and maybe as religions
have become less important and other
things we don't think about that so I
think it's so valuable that you've done
it and I think it's a real treat a great
gift thank you very much I really
appreciate it
very welcome inside yeah we're actually
not quite done yet you're not right off
the hook there's one more thing in the
interest of radical truth and radical
transparency we need to clear a few
rumors up about you okay so I'm going to
give you a series of statements and I
want you to tell us that these are true
or false okay
you played a pivotal role in the
creation of the Chicken McNugget I
thought so your devotion to meet
commodities led you to name your first
son after a cow true you caddied as a
child for Richard Nixon and the former
King of England true who's the better
golfer Richard Nixon actually uh and he
wasn't a very good golfer it imagine
he's in the water a lot I see yeah you
were inspired by the Beatles to take up
meditation and you still practice 50
years later true and one of the most
important things I think it's helped me
a lot you've committed to giving away
over half your wealth in your lifetime
yeah true you exclusively fly JetBlue
out of loyalty to Joel
he was chewing me out about that so
that's a no not yet
not yeah more roots you've worked for 44
years at Bridgewater but have never once
got promoted I got demoted of you do you
secretly wish that you went to Stanford
no comment
ladies and gentlemen a yahoo political
[Music]